Okay, a long question here. I was researching side effects of poor bone blockers that
my oncologist wanted to use district like tumors. And in articles, some women had
memory fog for 10 years or more. Don't know how many people get the worst side effects,
but after reading that, I almost prefer the breast surgery, which requires massive reconstruction.
I'll stop this because just because you have breast surgery doesn't mean that you have to do
reconstructive breast surgery. So, you know, there's women that are okay with not having breasts
anymore. So, doesn't mean you have to do the mass of reconstruction. Do you think I'm overreacting
overreacting to the side effects, I think? Yes, no, I don't think you're overreacting. I think you
need to be as cautious as possible and work out this the way you need to work through this in
your mind. I would caution you, but just because some people have had this horrible side effects of
something, doesn't mean you're going to have them. So, yeah, you know, just take that into consideration
when you're looking at just because you hear the worst of it, understand that that doesn't have to
be clear to you either. So, I don't know what to do. The only thing I can think is to double down
in the natural aroma chase inhibitors, and that's what you're taking with the supplements right now,
what's it you're talking about? One clear dip right now, what kind of protocol can you suggest
that I can present to a psychologist as a compromise to reduce the tumors? There isn't
a protocol under the sun that you could suggest to your oncologist as a compromise. They're not going
to accept that. So, I don't think that is something that you want to get into an argument with
your oncologist. You said last week that the estrogen itself isn't the cause of the cancer.
So, what else do I have to take more of so the tumor shrink as the estrogen diminishes? I feel like
I'm running out of time before the tumor comes through the skin. I sense your sense of urgency,
and you already are doing a lot of things, and if your tumor is very noticeably getting larger,
or getting closer to the skin surface, or bulging out, and you do have to think about maybe adding
some standards of care. I must be ready if it comes through since I do not want to be rushed in
anything. I agree. You don't want to be making decisions based on the emergency, so you want to have
time to think through these decisions beforehand. A holistic doc I know recommended Xymogen products
for natural hormone balance. Myronase and alcoplex. So, alcoplex with Myronase is the product that we
sell in our store too, and it's a good product, but I am still in favor of the sulforazine
by US enzymes as a better product. That is literally the same thing, but US enzymes has a
reputation of having a cleaner product. I could personally know the doctor that formulated the
sulforazine as a brand of mine, and it took them a long time to get, took them over a year to find
a source with the purest sulfur product with the purest Myronase in it. So, I would suggest the
sulforazine by US enzymes versus the Xymogen. When I like Xymogen products, we sell them, but I just
think the US enzymes are far superior product. I found a legitimate GCNAF source through a trusted
natural doc in Michigan. If you would like his info, you could email it to me. That would be great.